- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première question
va être posée
par monsieur Ian Boucard
pour le groupe
Les Républicains.
- Ian Boucard: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie
et des Finances.
Mercredi dernier,
lors de sa conférence
de presse, le président
a longuement évoqué
nos compatriotes
qui gagnent déjà
trop pour être aidés
et pas assez
pour bien vivre,
la France populaire,
la France des classes
populaires,
celle qui dit
que ce n'est jamais
pour elle qu'on propose
quelque chose
et pourtant,
c'est celle qui tient
le pays.
Le constat est juste,
mais il aura fallu
sept ans au président
pour comprendre
le drame que vit notre pays.
L'impossibilité pour certains
de vivre correctement,
de faire vivre décemment
leurs familles
grâce aux revenus de leur travail.
7 ans pour se rendre
compte
que dans notre pays,
certains
ne vivent pas correctement.
Chacun se rend compte
en remplissant
son caddie de courses
ou son réservoir
de carburant que les produits
de grande consommation,
ces produits essentiels,
ont augmenté
de 24,8% depuis janvier 2022.
Ce n'est pas fini.
En ce début d'année,
le gouvernement
a décidé d'aggraver
les choses
avec une nouvelle
taxe infligée
aux Français, la hausse
de 9,8% du prix
de l'électricité.
Lorsque l'on gouverne,
il y a la parole,
mais il y a surtout les actes.
Vous prétendez
vouloir protéger
les classes moyennes.
Dans les faits,
vous réinstaurez la taxe
sur la consommation d'électricité.
Alors que les Français n'ont
jamais été autant
en difficulté,
alors qu'ils ont multiplié
les efforts pour diminuer
leur consommation électrique,
leur facture énergétique n'auront
jamais été aussi élevées.
C'est le résultat de décisions
politiques graves,
celle de votre gouvernement.
Comptez-vous enfin
prendre conscience
des difficultés
de ces millions de Français?
Etes-vous prêts à annuler
cette hausse scandaleuse
du prix de l'électricité?
Qu'allez-vous
faire concrètement
pour améliorer
le pouvoir d'achat
des Français et pour passer
de la parole
aux actes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Monsieur le député,
pour répondre
à votre question,
le ministre de l'Economie
est en déplacement
avec le président
de la République.
Cet agenda était connu de tous.
Je me permets
de le rappeler ici
et de vous répondre sur ce sujet
extrêmement important,
si vous le permettez.
Dès le début de la crise,
avec la majorité présidentielle,
nous avons protégé
les Français
avec la mise en place
d'un bouclier tarifaire
pour éviter aux Français
une hausse massive
de factures que tous
nos voisins européens
ont connu en 2022 et 2023.
Sans l'action
du gouvernement,
le tarif réglementé de vente
d'électricité aurait doublé.
L'Etat a pris en charge
de façon assez évidente
plus de la moitié
de la facture
des Français et nous continuons
à agir massivement
sur le prix
de l'électricité en 2024,
avec le maintien de la taxe
sur l'électricité
en dessous de son niveau
de pré-crise,
avec le maintien
du chèque énergie,
de l'amortisseur électricité,
du plafond pour les TPE
et des aides
pour les entreprises.
Certaines ont signé
des contrats
au pire moment de la crise.
Nous agissons aussi
sur le long terme
pour que les prix
restent
les moins chers
en Europe,
comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui,
avec la relance
de la production nucléaire,
le plan sobriété,
la réforme du marché européen
de l'électricité.
Je vois que visiblement,
ces sujets
ne vous intéressent
que trop peu.
Je viens de répondre
à votre question qui,
visiblement,
ne vous intéresse pas.
Peut-être aviez-vous
une question
pour vos collègues
sénateurs majoritairement
de votre famille politique.
Peut-être pourriez-vous
les interroger
sur la raison
pour laquelle
ils ont demandé,
lors du projet de loi
de finances,
de rétablir massivement
la fin du bouclier
tarifaire
et nous serions,
au 1er février,
avec cet abonnement
qui a été rejeté,
à 15% d'augmentation.
Désolée
de ne pas avoir pu
être plus entendue.
La prochaine fois,
ce sera important.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Ian Boucard:
10% d'augmentation d'électricité,
1,14% d'augmentation
du SMIC, voilà
vos actions pour la France
qui travaille.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Anne Le Hénanff
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Anne Le Hénanff: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre
de la Transition écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
Depuis le 1er janvier 2024,
le dispositif
d'aide aux travaux
de rénovation énergétique
bénéficie d'une enveloppe
de 1,6 milliard d'euros
supplémentaires,
mais comporte
surtout de nouvelles règles
plus contraignantes,
lesquelles
sont sources d'inquiétude
pour de nombreux artisans
et petites entreprises
du bâtiment.
Cette actualisation
s'inscrit
dans la volonté
du gouvernement d'accélérer
la transition énergétique
des logements
en favorisant
les travaux d'ampleur
pour la rénovation.
Cela se traduit
par un recentrage
des aides sur des bouquets
de rénovations
en vue d'atteindre 200.000
rénovations globales
en 2024.
Cependant, les associations
et fédérations d'artisans
et de petites
entreprises du bâtiment,
que j'ai rencontré
dans ma circonscription,
redoutent les conséquences.
Tout d'abord,
les rénovations globales
sont contraignantes
pour les logements occupés.
L'entreprise doit
désormais être certifiée
et reconnue garant
de l'environnement.
Il s'agit d'un agrément
complexe à obtenir,
surtout pour les petites
structures.
Ils craignent
que les grands groupes
à dimension régionale,
voire nationale,
soient favorisés
sur le marché
à leur détriment.
Dans un contexte
de marché déjà difficile
pour ces entreprises,
ils ont adressé
un courrier à l'ancienne
Première ministre,
madame Elisabeth Borne,
afin de l'alerter
sur cette situation et faire
des propositions alternatives
concrètes afin
de ne pas exclure
les 600.000 artisans
et PME concernés
sur nos territoires.
Par exemple, à la place
de la certification
de l'entreprise,
ils proposent qu'une fois
les travaux effectués
par l'entreprise,
une certification de fin
de chantier viennent attester
de la conformité des travaux.
Ainsi, quels éléments
pouvez-vous
nous apporter afin
de lever les inquiétudes
des artisans?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
les bâtiments, c'est 20%
de nos émissions.
Faire en sorte
que l'on soit capable
de les rénover,
c'est bon pour la planète,
pour le pouvoir d'achat,
avec un angle particulier
pour les passoires thermiques.
Ce que vous évoquez,
ce sont des modifications
qui sont intervenus
il y a quelques jours
avec un double
objectif: continuer
à massifier le nombre
de rénovations énergétiques
et augmenter la qualité
des rénovations conduites.
Il y a eu
de grands progrès
avec Ma Prime Rénov'.
Ce n'est pas assez
par rapport
à nos objectifs.
Les nouveaux piliers
qui se sont mis
en place vont aider
pour les rénovations.
Vous évoquez un courrier
en particulier.
Il a retenu
mon attention en qualité
de ministre, mais il a aussi
retenu l'attention
du nouveau Premier ministre,
Gabriel Attal,
dans un contexte
où les propos du président
de la République
sur la nécessité d'aller
vers des simplifications
trouvent
un écho par rapport
à ces nouveaux dispositifs.
Vous évoquez en particulier
les groupements momentanés
d'entreprises
qui sont un moyen
pour les artisans
de pouvoir répondre
de manière collective
et d'éviter
de laisser les travaux
aux grands groupes.
Vous évoquez
la simplification
avec le RGE.
Dans le courant
du mois de février,
je vais réunir
un comité de suivi
de la rénovation
énergétique avec l'ensemble
des forces vives,
et notamment les artisans,
pour regarder
ce que nous pouvons simplifier
et la façon dont,
tout en continuant
à garder le rythme
sur la transition écologique,
nous pouvons
faciliter la vie
de ceux que ça concerne.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Jordan Guitton
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Jordan Guitton:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Je tiens d'abord à saluer
le travail remarquable
de nos forces
de l'ordre qui oeuvrent
chaque jour à la protection
des Français.
Le chaos sécuritaire
s'accentue toujours
plus avec des chiffres
vertigineux.
En 2023, 1000 agressions par jour.
Le chaos sécuritaire tue,
jusqu'aux agriculteurs,
qui manifestent
légitimement
et à qui je veux aussi
rendre hommage ici.
La délinquance
se répand jusqu'au
plus petit des villages.
Dans mon département
de l'Aube,
les cambriolages ont explosé
de 200% fin 2023.
Il y a 2 jours,
un tabac se faisait
encore braquer
dans mon territoire.
C'est un véritable
fléau qui menace
les Français
qui travaillent
chaque jour
et qui se voient voler
leurs biens et leur intimité.
C'est le résultat
de votre politique laxiste.
Dupond-Moretti,
Darmanin, même constat,
même échec.
Rien ne change.
En guise
de remerciement,
vous avez été reconduits
dans vos ministères.
C'est la prime à l'incompétence.
Votre volonté politique est nulle.
Combien d'individus
sont trop vite relâchés
et passent plus de jour
à récidiver
que de jours en prison?
La peur doit changer de camp.
D'ailleurs,
monsieur Darmanin,
vous dites vouloir terminer
le travail commencé,
mais vous n'avez rien commencé.
Les obligations de quitter
le territoire français,
9 sur 10 ne sont pas appliquées.
Nous l'avons vu encore hier.
La lutte
contre les agressions,
il y en a une toutes les 44
secondes.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur
avait trahi
sa famille politique
en disant rejoindre
le candidat du vide.
Aujourd'hui, le vide,
c'est l'ensemble
de votre gouvernement.
Allez-vous enfin
commencer quelque chose
pour protéger les Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Marie Lebec, ministre
en charge des relations
avec le Parlement.
- Marie Lebec: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Jordan Guitton,
je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser l'absence
de monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur.
Je vais essayer
d'apporter une réponse
à votre question
qui était somme
toute une mise en accusation
du gouvernement.
Vous avez soulevé
les cambriolages
dans votre département de l'Aube.
La lutte
contre les cambriolages
est une de nos priorités.
Les choses
se sont améliorées
grâce à la mobilisation
exceptionnelle
des policiers,
des gendarmes
et des magistrats.
Grâce à cette
mobilisation,
nous avons réussi
à inverser la tendance.
Pour être factuel,
alors qu'en 2022,
les cambriolages
étaient en hausse
de 11%, l'année dernière,
la hausse n'était
plus que de 3%.
Les derniers mois
de l'année 2023,
les cambriolages ont diminué.
Il y a une baisse de 2%
lors du dernier trimestre.
Il faut reconnaître
le travail
de nos policiers
et de nos gendarmes.
Certains départements
ont bénéficié d'une mise
en place un dispositif spécifique.
Les cambriolages
y sont en baisse
alors qu'ils avaient augmenté
en 2022.
Les cambriolages
de logements sont donc
en baisse.
Je vais prendre
quelques exemples symboliques.
Je pense au département
des Bouches-du-Rhône,
avec -6%.
La Loire-Atlantique, -14%.
En ce qui concerne Paris
et sa petite couronne,
il y a une baisse,
mais c'est encore insuffisant.
Dans votre département,
dans l'Aube,
entre 2017 et 2022,
les cambriolages
de logements
ont diminué de 6%
et cela a été
rendu possible
grâce à la hausse
des effectifs
de plus de 4%.
C'est notamment le résultat
des décisions prises
dans le cadre de la loi
de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur.
Outre les actions pour lutter
plus efficacement
contre les cambriolages,
je pense
au recrutement
massif d'effectifs,
la création de nouvelles unités
de gendarmerie...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
Monsieur le député?
- Jordan Guitton:
Par votre réponse,
on comprend
que c'est une baisse
de la hausse, donc
la hausse continue.
C'est votre bilan
qui est calamiteux
en termes sécuritaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Edouard Bénard
pour le groupe GDR.
- Edouard Bénard: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie
et des Finances.
Celui-ci a annoncé
ce dimanche une hausse
des tarifs réglementés
de vente d'électricité
au 1er février de +9,8%
pour les usagers
en heures creuses
alors même
que les prix de gros
de l'électricité
ont baissé de 30%
sur le dernier semestre.
Cette augmentation
de la seule volonté
de votre gouvernement,
qui a décidé d'enlever
la taxe intérieure
sur la consommation finale
d'électricité.
Depuis 2022,
les Français ont vu
leur facture flamber de 43%.
Tandis que 12 millions
de nos concitoyens
sont déjà confrontés
à la précarité énergétique,
cette nouvelle hausse
relève du racket pur
et simple.
Les récents
travaux réalisés
par le conseil social
et économique central d'EDF
démontrent que de nouveaux
calculs reprenant
les calculs
permettraient de réduire
les factures
des usagers de 20%
tout en finançant
les nouvelles tranches.
L'échec de la libération
du marché européen
de l'énergie est patent.
Monsieur le ministre,
je vous le demande
avec mon groupe
et au nom de millions
de Français qui se serrent
déjà la ceinture,
renoncez à cette hausse
irresponsable
et veuillez engager
le chantier d'une reprise
en main publique de ce bien vital.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
C'est parfait.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot,
porte-parole du gouvernement.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Monsieur le député Bénard,
tout d'abord,
permettez-moi de saluer
votre arrivée
et de vous souhaiter
la bienvenue
dans cette institution,
dans ce bel hémicycle.
Nous avons plaisir à débattre
des idées et à faire avancer
le débat politique
et public
pour les Français
sur des sujets majeurs.
Il s'agit
du pouvoir d'achat
dans votre question.
C'est un enjeu
de préoccupation
et un défi auquel
la majorité présidentielle
et le gouvernement
s'attachent à répondre
avec un certain
nombre de mesures
qui ont été mises
en place, notamment
dès le nouveau quinquennat,
qui s'est ouvert
en 2022,
avec la revalorisation
des retraites,
mais également la suppression
d'un certain
nombre de taxes,
comme la poursuite
de la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation,
la suppression
de la taxe audiovisuelle,
enfin, bref,
la liste pourrait
être longue,
mais je tiens
à vous le dire
parce que vous n'avez
peut-être
pas l'historique.
Tout cela a été
permis
grâce à cette majorité
présidentielle
parce que, oui,
nous avons permis
de faire voter
ces mesures concrètes
pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français
malgré un certain nombre
d'autres députés,
et je tiens à vous le dire,
attention, certains
de vos collègues
n'ont de gauche
que leur place dans l'hémicycle.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christian Baptiste
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Christian Baptiste: Merci.
Chers collègues,
ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Gabriel Attal,
Premier ministre.
La veille de votre nomination
à Matignon,
le journal Mediapart a révélé
que l'enquête administrative
lancée dans la foulée
du suicide
du jeune Lucas avait été bâclée.
A l'époque,
l'émotion était vive
les déclarations étaient unanimes.
Tous les anciens
ministres avaient exprimé
leur sidération.
Derrière l'émotion suscitée
par ce drame survenu
en janvier l'année
dernière, rien n'a été
fait pour savoir si le collège
de l'adolescent aurait pu prévenir
ce suicide.
L'enquête administrative
a été faite
avec le principal
de l'établissement,
qui minimise les faits.
Il n'a pas été auditionné.
L'homophobie
était omniprésente
dans l'établissement
depuis l'arrivée
de Lucas.
De fausses informations
ont a priori été livrées.
Rien n'a été fait
pour poursuivre
les coupables.
Pourquoi cette enquête
annoncée
par le gouvernement n'a
jamais été lancée?
Pourquoi avoir communiquer
sur une enquête administrative
qui n'a jamais existé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra,
ministre en charge
de l'Education nationale,
de la Jeunesse,
des Sports et des Jeux Olympiques.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
une école
qui ne transige
jamais sur le respect
de l'enfant et s'oppose
catégoriquement
au harcèlement.
Un enfant doit se sentir
bien à l'école.
Vous évoquez le cas de Lucas,
je veux évoquer également
toutes les autres
familles de victimes
depuis six ans.
Nous avons renforcé
notre action
contre le harcèlement,
notamment
avec la mise en place
du programme pHARe.
Lors de la journée
Non au harcèlement,
7 millions d'élèves,
du CE2 à la terminale,
ont répondu
à un questionnaire
pour déceler
les situations de mal-être
et de harcèlement à l'école.
Dans quelques jours,
nous aurons
la synthèse
de cette démarche inédite
et je communiquerai
une photographie
qui est claire.
Les équipes éducatives
sont mobilisées.
Le ministère
les a armés au niveau
des départements
et des académies
en déployant 150 postes
de responsables.
Nous allons avancer et aider
les parents d'élèves
à mieux détecter
les situations de harcèlement.
Aucune situation
ne doit rester
sans réponse,
tant pour les élèves victimes
que pour les élèves
auteurs,
que nous pouvons désormais
changer d'école,
y compris dans le primaire.
L'école de la République
est une école
qui doit protéger,
qui rend heureux,
et il n'y aura
aucune exception
à ce principe.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Christian Baptiste:
Beaucoup d'annonces,
mais très peu d'actes.
Je m'associe
à la peine de Nicolas,
un jeune Guadeloupéen
qui s'est suicidé
dans les Yvelines.
Une jeune fille a mis fin
à ses jours également.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
David Valence
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- David Valence:
Mes chers collègues,
ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre
de la Transition écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
Les Français
ont envie de trains
et ils le montrent.
L'année 2023 a battu
tous les records
en la matière.
+8% de fréquentation pour les TER.
Cela va à rebours
de certaines idées reçues.
Les Français
perçoivent les trains
comme complémentaires
et leur exigence vis-à-vis
de la SNCF est à la mesure
de leur attachement affectif
à l'opérateur
ferroviaire historique.
Ces réflexions faisaient état
de plusieurs choix,
soit la nécessité de récupérer
des rétributions
des collectivités
territoriales, voire
tout simplement de supprimer
certaines lignes.
Une ligne déficitaire
n'est pas forcément
une ligne qui est peu fréquentée.
Ca peut être une ligne
où les abonnés
sont majoritaires.
Les dessertes
comme Chambéry,
comme La Rochelle,
comme Laval,
comme
Charleville-Mézières
ou comme Saint-Dié-des-Vosges
seraient visées.
SNCF a tenu à démentir ces propos.
Je suis né en 1981,
année de lancement
du TGV par le président
François Mitterrand.
Pouvez-vous nous confirmer
que l'Etat regarde toujours
le train à grande vitesse
comme un outil d'aménagement
du territoire
et que la péréquation restera
bien la règle?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Madame la présidente,
mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le président,
y a-t-il des projets
de suppression de lignes
TGV à l'étude?
La réponse est non.
Y a-t-il des projets
de diminution
de fréquence sur des lignes
TGV existantes?
La réponse est non.
De façon extrêmement claire,
non seulement SNCF Voyageur
a démenti,
mais je suis en mesure
de le faire de la façon
la plus solennelle:
il n'y a aucune diminution
de service
sur les lignes TGV
qui soient à l'étude.
Maintenant,
ce n'est pas seulement
aux députés
que je m'adresse,
c'est au président
du comité d'orientation
des infrastructures.
Vous êtes né en 1981.
Cette décennie
marque le moment
où notre pays a fait
le choix des lignes
à grande vitesse.
Mais dans le même temps,
le financement
des lignes à grande
vitesse s'est
fait en diminuant
la régénération
des petites lignes.
Tout l'enjeu
pour nous aujourd'hui
est de tenir
dans un même mouvement
la poursuite
de la grande vitesse
et l'accentuation
de la régénération
qui entraîne, compte tenu
du sous-investissement,
des retards considérables
qui font parfois
la une de la presse
et qui ne font
pas honneur à notre groupe
et à la SNCF,
et plus largement
aux conditions
de désenclavement du territoire.
J'aurai l'occasion
vendredi de recevoir
le président
de la SNCF pour faire
un point précis
sur les dysfonctionnements
inacceptables
et répétés sur la ligne
qui va à Clermont-Ferrand.
Ce n'est pas la seule
sur laquelle
nous allons avancer.
Je veux redire
que les annonces
de la Première ministre
qui seront mises
en oeuvre
par ce gouvernement,
c'est 100
milliards d'euros
pour le ferroviaire d'ici 2040
et 1 milliard d'euros
de plus sur la régénération
des petites lignes
pour tenir les engagements
du président
sur les lignes du quotidien.
- David Valence:
Merci d'avoir rappelé
que l'Etat est décidé à passer
des consignes claires
en matière d'offre
de transport,
mais aussi en termes
d'investissement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Andrée Taurinya
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Andrée Taurinya:
Monsieur le ministre
des Affaires étrangères,
10.000 enfants tués,
24.000 morts,
des milliers
sous les décombres,
60.000 blessés,
des centaines de centres
de soins bombardés,
1,9 million de personnes
déplacées, voici
le bilan de plus de 100
jours de massacres
de masse.
La population affamée
de Gaza survit
au milieu de flaques
d'eaux usées
qui débordent des égouts détruits.
Pas de cessez-le-feu à l'horizon.
Pour une paix juste
et durable, le droit
des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes reste
notre boussole.
Qu'elle prenne la forme
d'une solution
à deux Etats
ou d'autres choses,
cela permettra de sortir
de cette situation.
Mais Netanyahou persiste.
Vous avez qualifié
d'inquiétante
sa déclaration.
La semaine dernière,
vous avez discrédité
la démarche de l'Afrique du Sud
de poursuivre Israël
pour génocide devant la cour
internationale
de justice.
Aujourd'hui,
vous semblez découvrir
la duplicité de ces dirigeants
qui sabotent
le processus de paix
depuis des décennies.
En avril 2017, le candidat
Macron s'engageait
à mettre toute son énergie
pour la paix
et la reconnaissance
de deux Etats
qui cohabitent.
Il promettait de condamner
les politiques
de colonisation.
10 ans
après la résolution votée
par l'Assemblée nationale,
la France va-t-elle enfin emboîter
le pas du candidat Macron
et reconnaître l'existence
de l'Etat palestinien,
comme vous-même
le préconisiez
devant le Conseil
de sécurité de l'ONU?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot,
porte-parole du gouvernement.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
avant de répondre
à votre question,
je veux excuser
le ministre en charge
qui présidait hier
le Conseil de sécurité
des Nations Unies,
précisément
sur la question
que vous posez aujourd'hui.
Cette réunion confirme
la priorité donnée
par la France à mettre
un terme au combat
que le Hamas a déclenché
le 7 octobre
par des attaques
terroristes
contre Israël.
Plus de 40 Français
sont morts et 3
sont encore en otage à Gaza.
A l'initiative de la France,
le Hamas fait
désormais l'objet
d'un régime de sanctions
spécifiques
de l'Union
Européenne car,
oui, c'est un groupe terroriste.
S'agissant
de la situation à Gaza,
elle s'aggrave
de façon dramatique.
La France est totalement
mobilisée
pour mettre un terme
à cette situation.
Elle est mobilisée
sur un plan humanitaire.
1000 tonnes de nourriture
et d'équipements
ont été déployés ainsi
qu'une aide médicale.
Une coopération étroite
avec la Jordanie complète
notre engagement.
Des enfants palestiniens
sont soignés
dans nos hôpitaux
grâce à l'action conjointe
du Quai d'Orsay
et du ministère
de la Santé.
La France est également
mobilisée
sur le terrain politique en vue
de redonner corps
à la solution
à deux Etats
que vous mentionnez
et qui est la position historique
de la France, mais aussi celle
du droit international.
C'est justement
l'objet de la réunion
du conseil de sécurité
et la France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
- Andrée Taurinya:
Nous attendons
cette reconnaissance
avec impatience.
Il y a vraiment urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Sébastien Peytavie
pour le groupe écologiste.
- Sébastien Peytavie:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le ministre,
mes chers collègues,
ma question aurait pu
être pour la ministre chargée
des Personnes handicapées,
mais il n'y
en a plus.
Finalement,
avec vous,
tout est une affaire
d'argent, même
quand il s'agit de dignité.
Je voulais m'adresser
à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
En avril dernier,
lors de la conférence nationale
du handicap,
le président
de la République a fait
une promesse importante
et attendue:
le remboursement intégral
par l'Assurance
maladie
de tous les fauteuils roulants.
Ces derniers jours,
les fabricants prestataires
et associations
m'ont alerté
sur les conditions de prise
en charge tarifaire
qui leur ont été présentées.
Il y aurait bien
une augmentation
de la base de remboursement
à 2600 euros
pour les fauteuils
manuels et 18.000 euros
électriques,
mais un plafond du même montant
serait instauré.
Nous nous retrouverions
alors dans une situation ubuesque.
Tous les modèles
au-dessus du plafond
ne seraient
plus du tout remboursés.
Un exemple simple:
regardez mon fauteuil,
monsieur le ministre.
Il n'est pas
spectaculaire,
il n'est pas extravagant,
il est juste adapté,
léger, maniable et sur-mesure.
Ce fauteuil coûte
aujourd'hui 8000 euros.
Ce n'est pas un luxe,
c'est une question d'autonomie
et de dignité.
Avec les nouvelles
conditions de prise
en charge,
mon fauteuil ne serait
plus du tout remboursé.
Nous l'avons vu
avec le PLFSS,
votre seule volonté
est de contenir
les dépenses au détriment
du bien-être
et de la dignité.
Que fait-on,
monsieur le ministre,
pour ces personnes
qui vont devoir payer
la totalité du prix
du fauteuil roulant
alors que ces personnes
n'y arrivaient
déjà pas avec un reste à charge?
Que fait-on
pour ces parents
qui vont devoir
payer le fauteuil
de leurs enfants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Vautrin,
ministre du Travail,
de la Santé
et des Solidarités.
- Catherine Vautrin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député, nous avons,
la semaine dernière,
lors de ma première venue
dans cet hémicycle,
évoqué ce sujet très important.
Vous avez raison,
le président
de la République
a pris un engagement.
Il l'a pris
devant la conférence nationale
du handicap.
Le sujet, c'est celui
de l'autonomie.
L'engagement
du président,
c'est le remboursement
intégral,
c'est l'engagement qu'il a pris.
Nous sommes à un moment
où il y a une concertation
entre les associations
de patients d'une part
et d'autre part,
l'ensemble des fournisseurs.
C'est dans cette
concertation
que nous devons
trouver les réponses
et travailler ensemble
sur le sujet.
C'est le sens
de l'échange
que j'ai eu
avec vous la semaine dernière
et je suis à
votre disposition
pour que nous puissions
continuer
sur le sujet.
L'autonomie des personnes
ayant besoin
d'un fauteuil roulant,
c'est l'une
des réponses
les plus concrètes
que nous pouvons apporter
à nos concitoyens.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
S'il vous plaît!
La parole à monsieur
Richard Ramos
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Richard Ramos:
Madame la présidente,
mes chers collègues,
j'associe
à ma question
mon collègue spécialiste
du numérique
au mouvement démocrate.
Vous avez renforcé
les dispositions permettant
à l'Etat de s'opposer
à une opération
de rachat d'actifs stratégiques
d'entreprises françaises.
Ces derniers mois,
un fleuron
est dans la tourmente.
C'est un groupe
qui emploie
plus de 100.000 personnes.
Cela
est dramatique
car dans moins de 200 jours,
le monde entier aura
les yeux rivés sur Paris
avec les Jeux Olympiques.
Le groupe Atos a été
choisi pour livrer
les infrastructures
de ce grand événement.
La situation
dans laquelle se trouve
ce groupe
est le résultat de près
de six mois d'attentisme.
Ce nouveau PDG
américain envisage
une vente à la découpe
de plusieurs activités
stratégiques du groupe.
L'une a des Allemands,
l'autre des Canadiens.
Le plan
de démantèlement aurait
pour conséquence
une casse sociale
sans précédent avec 6000
emplois menacés juste
en France.
Ce serait près
d'un milliard d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires
en moins sur l'activité
du groupe.
Comment pouvons-nous imaginer
qu'un leader français puisse
se déclarer en faillite
à seulement
quelques semaines des JO?
Envisagez-vous de protéger
les entreprises françaises
et ses salariés et d'assurer
qu'une entreprise française
qui a des capacités
puisse tenir
ses engagements
et sauver ses emplois
dans cette République française?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
Bruno Le Maire,
le ministre de l'Economie
et des Finances,
me charge de vous répondre
car il est avec le président
de la République
en déplacement.
Vous avez raison,
c'est une entreprise stratégique
pour la France.
L'Etat suit de très près
la situation
de cette entreprise
et assure
que les intérêts souverains
seront respectés.
Nous n'hésiterons pas
à mobiliser
les outils nécessaires,
notamment
le contrôle
des investissements étrangers
dans notre pays, en France.
Le code monétaire
et financier soumet
à l'autorisation
du ministre de l'Economie,
des Finances
et de la Souveraineté
industrielle
et numérique une prise
de participation importante
d'un acteur étranger
sur une entreprise sensible.
Atos a besoin
d'investissements privés
et d'industriels
pour se développer
dans les marchés du numérique.
Le rôle de l'Etat
est donc de protéger
ses actifs essentiels
et stratégiques.
Ils continueront à l'être.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Michel Castellani
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Michel Castellani:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, à la suite
des émeutes
qui ont succédé au drame
de la prison d'Arles,
le président
a décidé d'ouvrir
un dialogue de fond
avec les élus de la Corse.
Je voudrais rendre
hommage à la volonté
de trouver une réponse
à la situation
en Corse.
C'est compliqué,
de par l'existence
d'un peuple,
de sa culture de tradition
et du sentiment d'appartenance.
Cette réalité
est difficile à prendre
en compte dans les structures
centralisées
dans l'Etat-nation,
comme il est difficile
de prendre
en compte les difficultés
économiques
et sociales.
L'idée
n'est pas de se singulariser
par coquetterie,
mais de trouver
un chemin institutionnel
pour porter
le projet global
que les Corses attendent
depuis deux siècles.
Le projet avance
péniblement, en dépit
de l'impulsion
que voulait lui donner
le président de la République.
Quel est votre sentiment
et quelle suite voulez-vous donner
à ce processus?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal: Merci.
Monsieur le député
Michel Castellani,
le 28 septembre
dernier, à l'occasion
du 80e anniversaire
de la libération
de la Corse à Ajaccio,
le président
a pris des engagements clairs,
des engagements
qui sont en cohérence
avec une nouvelle approche
qu'il avait eu
l'occasion d'exprimer
à plusieurs reprises,
et notamment
pendant la dernière
campagne présidentielle.
Ces engagements,
je vous le dis de manière claire,
nous les tiendront.
D'abord, nous allons
poursuivre
les travaux visant
à faire apparaître
dans la Constitution
la mention
de la Corse,
d'affirmer au sein
d'un article la reconnaissance
d'une communauté insulaire
historique, linguistique
et culturelle.
C'était un engagement
du président
de la République.
Il y a ensuite
les responsabilités nouvelles
qui seront données
à la collectivité
de Corse en tirant les leçons
des insuffisances
du statut actuel.
Concrètement, il s'agit
de pouvoir adapter
les règles et même les lois.
Là encore,
le président a marqué
une ambition nouvelle et forte.
Nous pouvons,
si les élus de Corse
le décident, bâtir
une forme d'autonomie
à la Corse, c'est-à-dire
une autonomie
pour l'île et dans la République.
Le dialogue a commencé.
Je prends connaissance
des prises
de position des uns
et des autres
par voie de presse
ou dans le dialogue
avec les ministres,
mais le dialogue
se poursuit
et il va se poursuivre.
Nous devons
avancer ensemble
autour de bien
d'autres défis,
mieux enseigner le corse,
créer un service public
de l'enseignement
qui favorise le bilinguisme.
J'ai eu l'occasion
de travailler
sur cette question
en tant que ministre
de l'Education.
Il faut aussi répondre
aux défis immobiliers
sur l'île, créer une métropole.
Toutes ces pistes
sont discutées
au niveau insulaire
et elles doivent
être approfondies
dans une logique
de consensus.
Comment avancer?
Le président a invité
les acteurs corses
à agir dans les six mois.
Le ministre
de l'Intérieur se rendra
en Corse début
février pour faire
un point d'étape,
recueillir la contribution
de l'ensemble des acteurs.
Sur cette base,
mon gouvernement poursuivra
ses travaux en vue
de proposer au Parlement
les textes constitutionnels
et organiques nécessaires,
comme le président l'a rappelé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Monsieur le député?
- Michel Castellani: Merci.
Je prends acte
avec plaisir
de votre intervention.
Elle est importante.
Nous espérons tous
que le processus marquera
une étape décisive
dans l'histoire
de la Corse contemporaine.
Je voudrais
également ajouter
qu'il serait
important que Bastia,
qui a été
totalement ignorée
par le centralisme
régional exacerbé,
trouve enfin la place
qui doit lui revenir
dans la vie politique
et institutionnelle
de la Corse.
J'espère que vous prendrez
conscience
de cette situation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.
Elle reprendra
à 15h sur le projet
de loi constitutionnel
relatif
à la liberté de recourir
à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse.